madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les mini
chers collègues cette question s'adresse
à vous madame la Première ministre
depuis maintenant plus d'une semaine
nous débattons sur le projet des
réformes de retraite essentiel pour
préserver notre système par répartition
nous assistons démunis à une forme de
dérive de notre vie politique dans
laquelle comme un miroir grossissant de
notre société on peine à débattre du
fond et nous nous arrêtons trop souvent
à l'agression de notre corps même si je
dois souligner que les outrances de
certains de nos collègues nous nous
engage pas et on doit les dénoncer
je veux d'ailleurs par ces quelques mots
remercier salut Olivier du socle pour la
compétence et la dignité dont il fait
preuve dans ses débats
s'exprimer madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire ce qu'il en est du
travail trans partisan sur nos
institutions pourriez-vous nous donner
un calendrier ainsi que la méthode
intégrant les parlementaires qui sera
retenu pour ses débats qui nous
semble-t-il